The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR YEN-JIE LEE:
Welcome back, everybody,
to 8.03 Today, we
are going to continue
the discussion of
symmetry matrix,
which we started last time.
And this is what
we have been doing.
OK?
So the thing which
we have been doing
is to solve the normal mode
frequencies of component
systems by looking at
equation of motion,
MX double dot equal to minus KX.
And in the end of the day,
what we are doing is really
to solve Eigenvalue problem--
M minus one K matrix
Eigenvalue problem.
And we have been exercising
this several times
the last few lectures.
And the M minus
one K matrix says
you're describing how each
component in the system
interact with each other.
OK?
So that's actually what
we are trying to do,
to solve the normal modes.
So we have been making
progress, and we
are increasing the number
of coupled oscillators
as a function of time.
And now we finally arrive
at our limit, which
is infinite system, right?
So basically, what we
have been discussing
is a special kind of
infinite system, which
actually satisfies
translation symmetry, right?
So in general, we don't know
how to solve infinite system.
If this system is
really complicated,
no symmetry, then who knows
how to solve this, right?
But very luckily,
in 8.03 we have
started to get a highly
symmetrical infinite system,
and in this case, it's
translation symmetry.
And that is really pretty
nice, and we can actually
use this example to learn
an interesting fact, which
we can see from the physical
system we discuss here.
So, one thing which we
have been discussing
is the space translation
symmetry matrix.
As a reminder, S
matrix, as defined here.
Basically, if you
have a vector A, which
describes the amplitude
of an individual component
in a system, basically
these vectors
have Aj, Aj plus one, Aj
plus two blah blah blah.
All those amplitudes are
included in this vector.
And what does this S matrix do?
It's actually the following--
so if A prime is
equal to S times A,
then the base
component of A prime
will be equal to Aj plus one.
OK, so that's actually what
this S matrix does to A vector.
OK?
So you can think about S
metrics as an operator.
It's actually picking
up the Aj plus
one component, and moving
it to Aj in the new vector.
OK?
So that's actually what
this S matrix does.
And we were talking about
the Eigenvector of S matrix.
For example, if A is an
Eigenvector of S matrix,
then we have this relation,
SA equal to beta A. Now,
beta is actually the
Eigenvalue of S matrix.
OK?
And then we also discussed
last time, that means,
based on this logical
extension, Aj prime
would be equal to
Aj plus one based
on the definition of S matrix.
And now this is going to be
equal to beta times Aj, right?
Because we assume that that A
vector is an Eigenvector of S
matrix.
OK?
That means Aj will be equal
to beta to the j A zero.
Right?
According to this relation.
Therefore, we can
conclude that Aj will be
proportional to beta to the j.
OK, beta is still
some coefficient,
which we have not determined,
and it can be anything.
OK?
So, in order to consider a
system of little masses, which
are oscillating up
and down instead
of going in one direction
forever or the amplitude
grows exponentially.
And we also don't
want the system
to have the amplitude
go to infinity
when we go to very very large
j value or very small j value,
therefore we limit
our discussion
in the case of beta
equal to exponential ika.
OK?
In this case, the absolute
value of beta is one.
Right?
OK, and that means--
OK, Aj is actually proportional
to beta to Aj, right?
So if you take a ratio of
Aj plus one and the Aj,
the ratio is beta.
If beta Is not equal to
one or its absolute value
is not equal to one,
then this Aj value
is going to be
increasing according
to a power law, right?
So the amplitude is
going to be, whoa,
going to a very, very
large value, right?
And that corresponds to some
kind of physical system,
but not corresponding
to oscillation.
OK?
And if we do this
and assume that beta
is equal to exponential ika.
OK, if we do this, what is going
to happen is the following.
So again, the ratio
of Aj plus one and Aj
is a fixed value beta,
equal to exponential ika.
But what it does is, instead
of changing the amplitude,
it's actually doing a
rotation in the complex plane.
OK?
So if this is Aj, J plus
one, J plus two, et cetera,
as a function of say j, the
variable, then what it does
is that this operation
multiplied by beta
is really a rotation
in the complex plane.
And while we actually see
in the physical system,
it's actually a projection of
this complex imaginary plane
to the real axis.
And that would give you a sine
function and cosine function.
So very interestingly,
if we choose wisely,
the beta to have
absolute value of one,
then that will give you a system
which is actually oscillating
up and down and the
amplitude is actually
confined within some value.
OK, so that is actually
quite interesting.
The other thing which I
would like to talk about is--
OK, I choose to have
exponential ika as my beta.
OK, why ka, right?
It looks really strange here.
Suddenly the k and and the
a are coming to play, right?
So what is actually the small a?
The small a is actually the
distance between little mass,
just a reminder.
So this is actually
the length scale
between all those
little mass, right?
Therefore, what I'm doing is to
factorize out the length scale,
and then we suddenly found that.
OK, after I do this, I define
beta equal to exponential ika
Instead of exponential
i theta, right?
So you can also do
exponential i theta, right?
But instead, I gave
theta a fancy name,
which is k times
a. a is actually
the distance between mass.
Then something interesting
happens, because k suddenly
also will have a meaning.
It's actually the wave number
of the resulting sine wave.
OK?
So that's actually
why we actually
factor out this a factor.
Then, after that, we
actually found out
the amplitude would
be proportional
to exponential ijka,
and j is actually
just a label of a phase
component in the system.
OK.
So, once we have solved
the Eigenvalue problem
for the symmetry matrix,
S, as we discussed before,
if you look at the slides, OK?
If S and the M minus one
K matrix, they commute.
OK?
Commutes means that you can
actually change S and and the M
minus one matrix, you
can swap them, OK,
when you multiply them together.
OK?
If you can swap S and
M minus one K matrix,
that means they commute.
And our conclusion
from last time
is that they will share
the same Eigenvectors.
OK?
Of course, not necessarily
the same Eigenvalue,
but they share the
same Eigenvector.
So that's great news!
Because instead of solving
M minus one K matrix, which
can be really
complicated; depends
on what kind of physical
system you are talking about.
I can solve S matrix
Eigenvalue problem.
OK?
And then this Eigenvector,
which I just found here,
is going to be the Eigenvector
of M minus one K matrix.
And that's actually really
making things much easier,
because now instead of solving
Eigenvalue problem of M
minus one K matrix,
what I am doing
is just multiplying M
minus one K times A,
then you can actually obtain
the normal mode frequency omega.
OK?
So that's the issue of
the great excitement.
What does that mean?
That means, if you have
all kinds of systems, which
are translation symmetric--
you can have a line,
you have however
many people together,
whatever a system
which is so on here.
They are all going to
have the same Eigenvector.
You see?
You already know
how they are going
to interact with each
other, and what is actually
the amplitude as a function of
j, which is the location label.
OK?
So that's actually
really wonderful.
So, in order to help
you with understanding
of this system some
more, we are going
to discuss another system
which is actually also
very interesting.
It's actually a spring--
OK, last time we discussed a
spring and mass system, right?
And then we solved it together.
And this time we are going
to solve a system which
is made of mass and strings.
Ok?
So that may actually copy--
OK, let me actually
introduce you
to this new system we are
going to talk about today.
It has many little mass
here, from left hand side
of the universe and right
hand side of the universe.
Take forever to actually
construct this system.
OK?
Then my student actually
carefully link them by strings,
and we make sure that the
string tension, OK, is actually
a fixed value, which is T. OK.
T is actually the
string tension.
And of course, as what
we discussed before,
the space or the distance
between little mass
is actually A. OK?
So that's, again,
the same length
scale, which we were using.
And finally, in
order to describe
all those little
masses in the system,
I label them as j, j plus one, j
plus two, et cetera, et cetera.
OK.
So, the question
we are asking is,
what would be the resulting
motion of this system, right?
So what we can do is what we
have done last time, right?
We take jth object
in this system,
and we look at the force
diagram and this M minus one--
to write down the equational
motion and also the
and M minus one K metrics.
So what is actually the force
diagram of j's component?
OK.
If I take this--
so first, I take my jth
mass, and it's connected
to two strings, right?
So there are two strings
connected to jth mass.
OK?
And of course,
left hand side you
have another mass, right hand
side you have another option.
OK?
And I know the tension
of this string.
Its actually a fixed
value, and the string
tension is fixed at the T. OK?
So, in order to
describe this system,
I need to find my
coordinate system, right?
As usual.
So, what is actually
the coordinate system
I'm going to use.?
So I need to define
horizontal direction
to be x, and the vertical
direction to be y.
Therefore, I cannot express
this little mass to be--
the position of jth little
mass as Xj and the Yj.
OK?
We can do the same thing
for the left-hand side mass
is Xa minus one, Yj minus one,
and Xj plus one Yj plus one.
So to simplify the discussion,
what I'm going to assume
is that all those little masses
can only move up and down, OK,
instead of back and forth.
OK, so only one
direction is allowed,
and also I assume that
the up and down motion
of all those little masses
is really really very small.
So I can use small
angle approximation.
OK, so therefore I can--
this is essentially the zero
of Y axis, when I actually--
before I actually move--
wind up with the mass away
from the equilibrium position.
So when the string mass
system is at rest, OK,
not really moving, then all the
mass are at Y equal to zero.
OK?
So now, I actually move
this mass to Yj, OK?
Then, apparently there are two
forces acting on this mass.
The left hand side
is string force,
and the right hand
side is string force.
And the magnitude of the
force is actually T. OK?
So, in order to help us
with solving this problem.
I would define two angles--
the left hand side angle to be
theta one, and the right hand
side angle to be theta two.
Then I can now write down
the equation of motion
in the horizontal direction, and
then in the vertical direction.
OK?
All right.
Since I have assumed
that all of those masses
can only move up and down,
now I mean-- and also
the displacement with respect
to the equilibrium position,
which is Y equal to zero, is
really small, compared to,
for example, the length scale a.
OK?
So therefore, I can write
that condition explicitly.
So I have a condition.
I assume that Yj is actually
much, much smaller than a,
which is the distance
between those masses.
And that means theta
one and theta two
are going to be much,
much smaller than one.
OK?
So that's actually
given us a chance
to use small angle
approximation.
So based on this
force diagram, I
can now write down the
two equations of motion;
one in the horizontal
direction, the other one
in the vertical direction.
So what I'm going to get
in the horizontal direction
is M X j double dot.
These will be equal to--
OK, there are two forces.
Right?
Horizontal direction,
I would need
to calculate the projection
to the X direction,
therefore the left
hand side force
will give you minus
T cosine theta one,
and the right hand side
of this string force
is going to give you
plus T cosine theta two.
OK?
And then in the vertical
direction, what I'm
going to get is Myj double dot.
This is equal to
minus T sine theta y.
Now I'm doing the
projection in the y
axis in the vertical direction,
and minus T sine theta two.
OK.
And since I have this
condition, all the mass
can only move up and down,
and also the displacement
is much, much smaller
than a; therefore, I
have the small
angle approximation.
Cosine theta is
roughly equal to one,
and the sine theta is
roughly equal to theta.
OK?
And I would call this
the equation number one,
and the second equation
in the vertical direction
to be equation number two.
OK.
So, up to here, everything
is essentially exact,
and now I would like to make
a small angle approximation
and see what will happen.
And now equation
number one will be
called MXa double dot
equal to minus T plus T,
and this is equal to zero.
OK, so that means we will
not have horizontal direction
acceleration.
Therefore, in the
horizontal direction,
there will be no
acceleration and therefore
no movement in the X direction,
or horizontal direction.
OK, and now I can take a look
at the vertical direction.
OK?
So basically, what I am going
to get is MYj double dot,
and this will be
equal to minus T. Now,
sine theta one will be
roughly equal to theta one.
So what is actually theta one?
Theta one is going to be--
OK, so this is actually
the Yj minus Yj minus one.
Right?
So now that's actually
the difference
between the amplitude of the
displacement of the mass j,
and the displacement
of mass j minus one.
Right?
Divided by a, I get theta one.
Therefore, the first
sine theta one,
will become Yj minus Yj
minus one, divided by a.
OK?
And of course, you can do the
same thing for the sine theta
two, right?
Which is actually
just the theta two.
Then, basically, what
I am going to get
is minus Tyj minus Yj
plus one divided by a.
OK.
Any questions?
I hope everybody
is following it.
OK, so now I can actually
simplify equation number two,
and basically, what I
am going to get is MYj
double dot will be
equal to minus T over a.
Basically, I take T
over a out of it again.
And I also collect all the
terms related to Yj minus one,
minus two Yj, plus Yj plus one.
OK, I just ask you to
rewrite equation number two
in a form which we like more.
OK, so that is actually the
equation of motion, so from now
on, I am going to
ignore all the motion
in the horizontal direction,
because in this small angle
approximation we have
shown you that there
will be no acceleration
in the x direction, right?
So now it's actually getting
a step forward again.
Basically, we have the
equation of motion,
and what is usually
the next step?
The next step is to
write down what matrix?
Anybody can help me?
STUDENT 1: M minus one k matrix.
PROFESSOR YEN-JIE LEE: M
minus one k matrix, right?
So actually, as usual, we
actually follow the procedure.
Now I would like to write
down the m minus one k matrix.
OK, so before I do that
what, I will define--
I will actually assume my normal
mode has this functional form,
yj is equal to the real part
of aj exponential i omega t
plus phi.
So basically, that tells
you that all the components
are oscillating at the
same frequency, omega,
and the same phase, phi.
Yes.
STUDENT 2: When
there's a scenario--
PROFESSOR YEN-JIE LEE: Yeah?
STUDENT 2: [INAUDIBLE]
also [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR YEN-JIE LEE: This one?
STUDENT 2: No, there
should be one [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR YEN-JIE LEE: Here?
STUDENT 2: Yeah.
PROFESSOR YEN-JIE LEE: Ah.
OK, maybe I made a
mistake somewhere.
Yeah I think it
should be plus, right?
OK.
All right.
Thank you very much.
So now we have all
the ingredients
and we assume that it has
a normal mode of aj, yj
in this functional form.
And then now I can--
the next step is to get
m minus one k matrix.
All right.
So what is actually m metrics?
M matrix is really
really straightforward.
It's m, m, m in
the diagonal terms,
and all the rest of
the terms are zero.
All right.
And those, of
course, you can also
write down k matrix, right?
So the k matrix
will be equal to--
there are many terms,
and in the middle
you have minus t over a, two
t over a, minus t over a,
and all the rest of
the terms are zero.
And of course these
patterns go on and on.
Minus t over a, two t over A,
minus t over a and zeros, et
cetera et cetera.
And this pattern is going to
go on forever, because this
is actually infinitly long
matrix, infinite times
infinitely long matrix.
OK, so once we have this,
we can now write down
the m minus one k matrix.
What is actually the
m minus one k matrix?
It has a similar structure
to k matrix, right?
All those are zeros--
OK, all those are
the other values,
but it has a fixed structure
minus t over ma, two t over ma,
minus t over ma, and then zeros.
And this will go on forever
in the diagonal term and also
the next two diagonal terms.
And all the rest of
the terms. are zero.
OK, Any questions?
OK, so that's really nice.
Now we have our m
minus one k matrix,
and the good news
is that you don't
have to solve m minus one k
matrix's Eigenvalue again,
right?
Because we have solved
the Eigenvalue problem
of s matrix, therefore
what is our left over
is to multiply m minus
one k by a, right?
a is actually one of the
Eigenvectors of s matrix.
OK, so I am going to
multiply that for you,
and now we calculate m minus
one k equal to omega square a,
then I can get omega square
out of this calculation.
OK?
If I again focus on this term.
OK, so basically,
what I am going to get
is, right hand side, I
have omega square aj, OK?
Now that's actually from
the right hand side, OK?
And left hand side m minus one
k times a, what I'm going to get
is t over ma minus aj minus one
plus two aj minus aj plus one.
All right?
Because if you take this term--
this term is actually
in the exact diagonal
of this m minus one k matrix,
therefore this matches with j,
and this will match with j minus
one; match with j plus one.
OK, therefore, if you multiply
m minus one k and the a, you get
this result. OK?
And we also know that aj is
proportional to exponential
ijka, right?
Therefore I can
take aj out of this
and basically I get t over
ma aj minus exponential minus
ika plus two.
Because I take aj out
of this bracket, OK.
And minus exponential ika.
OK.
Now I actually can cancel aj.
Basically, what I
get is, omega square
will be equal to t over ma
two minus exponential ika
plus exponential minus ika.
And that will be equal
to two t over ma.
OK.
One minus-- OK, so exponential
ika plus exponential minus ika,
you are going to get two
cosine ka, all right?
Therefore, you get
one minus cosine ka.
OK.
I define omega zero to be
square root of t over ma,
just to make my life easier.
OK?
Then, what is going
to happen is that I
will have omega
square equal to two
omega zero square
one minus cosine ka.
Any questions?
OK, of course if you like, you
can also rewrite this as four
omega zero square sine
square ka divided by two.
OK, so if you like.
OK, so look at
what we have done.
We studied a highly
symmetric system,
which is as you were
shown in the slide.
OK, basically you satisfy the
space translation symmetry.
OK?
Now what we have been
doing is to derive
the equation of motion,
make use of the small angle
approximation, then you
will be able to find that,
OK, only the y
direction is actually
moving as a function of time.
Therefore, based on this
derivation of m minus one k
matrix, I arrive, and also
based on the equation of motion,
which I derived from
the first diagram,
I get this m minus one k matrix.
And since we know that m
minus one k matrix and s
matrix will share
this Eigenvector,
I can multiply m minus one k
matrix, and I come back to a.
Then I will be able to
solve the functional
form of omega square, and
that is actually given here.
Omega square is equal to
two omega zero square y
minus cosine ka.
OK?
And is this actually telling you
that omega is a function of k.
OK.
What is k?
k is actually the wave
number and omega is actually
the angular frequency of
the normal modes, right?
So that means what we
were talking about--
that means if we fix the
wavelength or the wave number,
k, then there will be
a corresponding omega.
OK?
If you fix the wavelengths
you are talking about,
then the omega is also fixed
by this omega of k function.
OK, now we actually call
it dispersion relation.
This term may not
mean much to you now,
but later in the discussion,
you will find, aha!
It really makes sense, and that
we will talk about dispersion
in the later lectures.
OK, so the conclusion from
here is that, basically,
if I have this distance that
satisfies this translation
symmetry, then what it tells us
is that the normal modes, what
looks like some kind
of sinusoidal function,
as we discussed last time.
And also this--
OK, so this is actually
the amplitude, what
I am drawing here, this curve.
And all those masses are
only moving up and down, OK?
As a function of time.
And this is aj, and that is the
oscillation frequency, which
is actually the frequency
of moving up and down,
this kind of motion,
is actually omega.
And also, we learned that
omega is equal to omega of k.
And that is actually
decided by the length,
and how distorted is
this normal mode--
the shape of the normal mode?
And this is actually determined
by the k, which is actually
the wave number, and of course
you can also get the wavelength
from two pi over k.
OK?
In short, if you give
it a specific wave
number or wavelength, than
the oscillation frequency
is already fixed because
of the equation of motion,
which we did, right,
from the first diagram.
Any questions?
OK.
The last point which I
would like to remind you
is that, at this point,
since we are talking
about infinitely long
systems, therefore
all possible k are allowed.
Right?
Because, basically, you
have an infinite number
of coupled oscillators,
and therefore you
have an infinite
number of normal modes.
So all possible cases are
allowed, and that actually
because we have even an
infinitely long system.
After the break, which we
will take a five minute break,
we will discuss how to use
infinitely long systems
to actually understand
a finite system.
So you will see that,
actually I can use, now,
this space translation
symmetry, and to solve,
in general, infinitely
long systems.
And I can actually even go
back to find to a finite system
and see what we
can get from there.
OK?
So we will be back at 12:20.
If you have any
questions, I will be here
OK, welcome back, everybody.
So we will continue
the discussion.
So there were a few questions
asked during the break.
So, the first question is
related to how we actually
arrive at this equation.
And that is actually because--
OK, two t over ma is
actually really happening
in a diagonal term.
Therefore, if you
multiply m minus one k
matrix and A matrix, which
is actually shown there,
then you will get
this term, minus t
over ma multiplied
by aj minus one
plus two t over ma
times aj price minus t
over ma times aj plus one.
And that is actually why we
can arrive at this expression.
OK?
Then what happens
afterward is that we
found that aj can be factorized
out, and they cancel.
And then now, my solution
depends now upon the amplitude,
and still omega is actually
dependent on the k value, which
we actually choose.
OK.
The second question is, why
do I say k is the wave number?
OK, where is that coming from?
So that is because--
OK, so aj is proportional
to exponential ijka.
OK?
It has a fancy name.
If I take the real
part, OK, as we
did when we went
to the description
of physical systems,
then you get cosine jka.
OK?
And j times a is actually--
j is actually a label, right?
Labeling which mass
I am talking about.
A is actually the distance
between all those masses.
j times a will give you
the x location of the mass.
So j times a is actually the
the x position of the mass.
OK?
Therefore, if you accept
that, this becomes cosine kx,
and from there you
will see immediately
that k has a meaning, which
is actually the wave number.
OK.
All right, is that?
OK, so that was the
questions raised,
which I can quickly explain.
So, what I am going
to do now is that--
OK, we have solved, in general,
an infinitely long system.
What are actually the
resulting normal modes
of infinitely long systems?
It has an infinite
number of normal modes,
and we will wonder
if I can actually
borrow this
infinitely long system
and solve finite systems to see
if I can arrive at the solution
really quickly.
OK?
So the answer is actually yes.
So if I consider a finite
system that looks like this;
so I have many, many little
masses on this system
and they are connected
to each other
by the center strings,
which I prepared before, OK?
And I call this the
position in the y
direction of this object y1,
and then the next object y2, y3,
etc.
And I have an object
in this system
and both ends of the string
are fixed on the wall.
OK?
So I can actually now argue
that the infinitely long system
can help us with
the understanding
of this finite system.
Why is that?
That is because, now, I
can assume that, huh, this
is actually just part of
an infinitely long system.
All right.
So I construct my
infinitely long system,
and now I nail the yth mass,
I nail the y n plus one mass,
and I fix that so that
it cannot move, OK?
So it's still an
infinitely long system,
but there are two interesting
boundary conditions
at j equal to zero and
j equal to n plus one.
OK.
What are the two
boundary conditions?
The first one is y
zero equal to zero.
OK?
And the second condition is
y n plus one equal to zero.
OK?
So there are two
boundary conditions,
so basically what I'm looking
at is still an infinitely long
system, but I require
y zero and y n plus one
to satisfy these two conditions.
OK?
And we will find that,
huh, with this procedure,
we can also solve this finite
number of couple oscillators.
The problem, in this case
we, have coupled oscillators.
OK?
So the first thing which
I would like to say
is, based on the functional
form, the functional
form of omega square, now
this is equal to four omega
zero square sine
square ka over two.
OK?
What we actually have
is that omega k is
equal to omega minus k.
OK?
So both of them will give you
the same angular frequency.
OK, therefore, what
does that mean?
This means that
linear combination
of exponential ijka and the
exponential minus ijka--
OK, linear combination
of these two vectors--
is also an Eigenvector
of m minus one k metrics.
OK, so you can do
linear combination
of these two vectors.
OK, so if we do that, now
I can guess my solution
will be like yj equal to real
part of exponential i omega t
plus phi.
I can now have a linear
combination of exponential ijka
and the exponential minus ijka.
Basically, I have
alpha exponential ijka
plus beta exponential
minus ijka.
OK?
And I would like to
determine why that's actually
alpha and beta which actually
satisfy these boundary
conditions, one and two.
OK, so now I can use the
first boundary condition,
y zero equal to zero, right?
So j equal to zero.
Therefore, basically, what I
get is, when j is equal to zero,
then this is actually one and
this is actually one, right?
And this actually gives
you y zero equal to zero.
If y zero is equal
to 0 at all times,
no matter what t as you give it
to this system, then basically
you have alpha plus beta
equal to zero, right?
Because j is equal to zero.
So you have alpha plus beta, and
that has to be equal to zero.
Therefore, you can conclude that
alpha is equal to minus beta.
And I've reused the
second boundary condition,
y n plus one equal to zero,
because I nailed this mass
and then fixed that so
that it cannot move.
Then basically, what you get is
y n plus one is equal to zero,
then basically you have
alpha exponential i n
plus one ka plus--
okay, so beta is your equal
to minus alpha, right?
So basically, you can get
minus exponential minus i
n plus one ka, right?
Multiplied by alpha.
And now this is
actually equal to zero.
Now we have the choice.
We can actually set alpha
to be equal to zero,
but if I set alpha
then beta is also zero.
Then I have zero
everywhere, right?
Then there's no oscillation.
And that's not fun, right?
OK.
Therefore, what I'm
going to set is actually
the second turn equal to zero.
OK.
The second turn, I
can actually simplify
that to be two i
sine n plus one ka.
And now this is
actually equal to zero.
OK.
What is actually the condition
of this thing equal to zero?
Basically, n plus 1 is
actually a given number,
a is actually the distance
between those masses,
therefore, what I can actually
change is the k value.
Right?
So I can now solve
this condition,
and I will conclude
that k will have
to be equal to n times
pi divided by N plus one.
I hope you can see it.
Where small n is equal to one,
two, three, until capital N.
So what does that mean?
This means that--
OK, originally, before I
introduced the boundary
condition, this system
is infinitely long, OK,
and it has an infinite number
of normal modes, right?
But once I introduced
these boundary conditions,
which I actually require
y zero equal to zero,
because I fixed this
point on the wall.
Y m plus one equal to zero
because I fixed, also,
that point on the wall.
Something really happened.
Now it actually gives us, first,
the shape of the system when it
is actually in the normal mode.
Basically, the shape--
what I mean here
is the amplitude as
a function of j, OK?
That's actually what
I mean by shape, OK?
The shape is now
like a sine function.
That's the first thing
which we get from here.
The second thing
which we get here
is that now, the k values
are not arbitrary anymore.
The k values are equal
to n pi over n plus one.
And the the small n is actually
equal for one, two, three,
until N. So now, once you
actually fix this two point,
you actually have only
how many normal modes?
N normal modes!
Right?
So what I want to tell
you is that, in general,
the sinusoidal shape is
actually fixed already
by this translation
symmetry argument.
OK.
And once we nail both sides--
actually, we also
restrict ourselves
to the discussion of only a
few k which actually satisfy
the boundary conditions.
And if I plot all those normal
modes as a function of i,
basically what you
can see from here,
you can see if I have n
equals to one and capital
N equal to four in this case.
OK, so I have four--
basically, I'm going to
have four normal modes.
The first one will be like
a really long wavelength
one, when n is equal to one.
And if I increase
the small n value
so that the k becomes
bigger, then you
can see that there is more
distortion when this system is
in one of the normal modes.
And this shape is actually going
to be oscillating up and down,
instead of--
OK, so all those points are
only moving up and down, right?
Just a reminder.
OK?
And why do we have
all those cases?
Because of the
boundary conditions.
OK, any questions?
OK, so I have
several other cases,
which is open end and
the closed end, and also
the driven and the coupled
oscillator examples.
Also in the lecture notes,
but unfortunately, we
are will not be able
to go over them,
but I think they are
very, very detailed,
the notes in the lecture notes.
OK.
So, let me-- before I
move on to the discussion
of continuous
systems, OK, I would
like to discuss with you
what we have learned so far.
So what we have learned is
that, if I have a symmetry which
is a translation
symmetry, and plus,
we only limit ourselves in
the discussion of oscillation.
OK, in other words,
we limit the amplitude
so that it doesn't explode
at the edge of the universe.
OK.
And I will give you
a beta value which
is the functional form
of exponential ika,
and equation of motion can be
derived from the first diagram.
Once we entered the
equation of motion,
we can get m minus
one k matrix, then
we can derive omega square
from this expression.
And finally, we actually can
simplify everything and then
get the dispersion
relation omega
equal to omega k, which is a
function of k, the wave number.
Before we actually introduce
boundary conditions
to go from an infinitely long
system to a finite system,
all the k values are allowed.
Once you introduce
boundary conditions,
you find that you only have a
limited number of normal modes.
Second, the k value not
continuous at any value
any more, it becomes discrete.
And only n values allowed
from this exercise.
And finally, what is actually
the most general solution
is actually the
linear combination
of all those normal
modes, which we show here.
And what is actually the ratio
between all those normal modes?
All those free
coefficients are determined
by initial conditions
if you are given.
OK?
So that's actually what
we have learned so far.
And now I would like
to make a leap of faith
to see what happens.
OK, what we are going to
do is to introduce you
to a continuous infinite
number of coupled oscillators.
OK?
So what does that mean?
What I am going to do
is to go from this--
so I have t and then a t, a
lot of string and mass system,
et cetera, et
cetera, but I would
like to go from there to just
an infinitely long string
with string tension t and
some kind of density or mass.
OK?
We like to make it continuous
to see what will happen.
OK?
So, just a reminder of the
jth term of the m minus one
k matrix operation.
Basically, we have m minus
one k times a, the j's term
of m minus one k a.
That is actually given
by omega square aj.
This is equal to t over
ma minus aj minus one
plus two aj minus aj plus one?
OK.
So this is actually just a
copy of that formula here.
OK, so if I make it continuous--
OK, so that means
what I'm going to get
is omega square a but
evaluated at position
x, where x is actually
equal to j times a.
OK?
And this will be
equal to t over ma
minus a, evaluated at x minus a
plus two a x minus a x plus a.
Now I am going to make this
a very, very small, right?
So that, when I make
a very, very small,
then it becomes a very,
very continuous system.
OK?
So what I'm going to do is--
I can now make a go to zero.
I can now use Taylor's
series fx plus delta x--
and just a reminder, if you
do a Taylor expansion of this,
you are going to get f of x
plus delta x f prime x plus one
over two factorial delta
x square f double prime x.
OK, so that means
now, I can actually
do a Taylor expansion of a x
minus a and then a x plus a.
So what I'm going
to get is like this.
So a x minus a
will become a of x
minus a a prime x plus one over
two a square a double prime x.
I can also do the same thing
to do a Taylor expansion
for a x plus a.
a x plus a will be equal to a
of x plus a prime x plus one
over two a square
a double prime x.
OK.
Once I have done this,
basically, then, I
can calculate minus a
x minus a plus two a
of x minus a x plus a.
OK, I'm just taking the middle
term and copying it there.
OK?
If I use, now, this expression,
OK, then basically I
will see that, OK, a of x
terms actually cancel, right?
Because I have two a of
x from these two terms,
and they cancel
with this two a x.
OK?
And also, a prime terms,
also cancel, right?
Because you have a x minus
and a x plus a, therefore,
the x prime turns cancel here.
This is a minus sign,
this is a plus sign.
You see?
So therefore, what is actually
left over is all those terms.
This is going to give you
a double prime x a squared,
plus many other higher
order terms, right?
Because those are
actually not completed,
we have many, many
higher order terms.
OK?
In the limit of x go to zero--
Yes.
STUDENT: Isn't the
xa prime [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR YEN-JIE LEE: Yeah.
Oh yeah, you are right.
Thank you very much.
OK, thank you for that.
So there should be a minus
sign in front of it, OK.
So basically what we have is a
double prime x times a square
plus some higher order turn of
a cubed, et cetera, et cetera.
OK, since we are talking about
the limit of a goes to zero,
we can safely ignore all
the higher order terms.
OK?
So now, if we go back to
this equation, omega square a
will become, basically,
t over m minus t over ma
a double prime x
times a squared.
OK, and then plus some
higher order terms.
OK, now I can define rho l to
be equal to m divided by a.
OK.
And I will I will have
to be very careful when
I go to the continuous
limit, OK, I also
do not want to make this system
infinitely massive, right?
Therefore, I would like
to fix the rho l when
I go to the continuous limit.
So basically what I am doing is
that I cut this system in half
so that a becomes smaller and
the mass also because smaller,
so that rho l stays
as a constant, OK,
when I go to a continuous limit.
OK, so what I'm going
to get is omega square a
will be equal to minus t
over rho l a double prime x.
And to write it explicitly,
this is actually
equal to minus t over rho l.
I'll just square a
partial x squared.
OK?
Because each prime is
actually the differentiation
which is spread to x, right?
OK.
Don't forget-- what
is actually this?
This is actually m
minus one ka, right?
Equal to omega square a.
And that this is
actually just partial
square a partial t square.
Right?
Because this is actually
m minus one k matrix.
It's actually originally-- going
back to the original equation,
we are actually solving
m x double dot equal
to minus kx problem, right?
So there should be a
minus sign there as well.
Right?
So mx double dot
equal to minus kx,
therefore x double dot will be
equal to minus m minus one kx.
Right?
So minus m minus one k matrix
will be equal to x double dot,
right?
Therefore, what this is
actually x double dot?
It's basically-- in the
current presentation,
it's actually just partial
square a, partial t square.
OK?
Can everybody accept this?
OK, so now we have
some sensibility
going from a discrete
system, which
you have a length scale of
a, to a continuous system,
because a goes to zero.
By a certain time, I fix
the ratio of m and a so
that the system doesn't
grow too infinitely massive.
OK, so if I do this, then in
short, you get this equation.
Partial square a
partial t square,
and that is equal to t
over rho l partial square
a partial x square.
OK?
I can now define vp as equal
to square root of t over rho l.
OK?
And this will become the
p square partial square
a partial x square.
What is this?
This is what equation?
Wave equation!
OK, you see that now?
After all the hard
work, OK, going
from infinity long
systems, discrete systems,
then go to a
continuous limit, we
discovered the wave equation.
This is probably the
most important equation
you actually learn, until now.
More important than
f equal to ma, right?
Because you can
listen to my lecture,
even, if this equation
didn't exist, right?
Then I can not propagate
a sound wave to your ear.
Right?
And you cannot even
see the black board,
because the
electromagnetic wave,
which I will show
in a later lecture,
also kind of satisfies
the same function or form.
So I think this is an
achievement and a highlight
of today's class.
We actually realize
now, what we have
been doing is really
solving something
related to the wave equation.
And next time, what I would like
to actually discuss with you
is the solution of
this wave equation.
So here, I have--
again, last time
you have seen this.
This is a coupled
oscillator system.
It has 72 components.
As a physicist, that's actually
equal to an infinite number
of coupled oscillators, OK.
That's good enough.
And you can see
that, if I do this,
it does something
really strange, right?
You see a progressing
wave going back and forth,
and it disappears
because of friction.
OK?
If I can construct
something closer
to a perfect coupled
system without friction,
what is going to happen
is that this wave
is going to be there bouncing
back and forth forever.
And that actually
can be understood
by the wave equation.
And also, if I oscillate this
system at a fixed frequency,
you will see that these
become standing waves.
And of course I can
I do crazy things,
I can oscillate and stop it
and it becomes really, really
complicated motion.
And of course you are
welcome to come here and play
after the class.
And next time, on
Thursday, we are
going to talk about the
solution to this equation
and how to understand
all kinds of fancy motion
this system can do,
given by the nature.
Thank you very much.